Good Morning Hank, it's Tuesday!
I'm Maureen Johnson filling in for John Green because once again,
he has contributed to the birth of a human child.
This is really nerve-wrecking for me, because I'm a writer, like John,
but like, I don't make videos all the time,
and, y'know, I don't think I'm really good at it.
So, y'know, I got my camera, I got my watermelon
(chews)
Today's topic is:
The INTERNET!
Yeah, the internet, the whole thing.
Some people don't like the internet.
And it can be for a number of reasons.
For example, there are people like my Mom,
who gets confused by the internet and generally doesn't know how it works
and is constantly afraid she's going to break it.
[Maureen's "Mom":] Maureen? Maureen, Maureen!
The people that hate or dismiss the internet often say things
like "Well, back when I was a kid, you know, we didn't just sit around
and watch porn all the time and make animated JIFF-ies!"
Yeah, that may be true, but you probably also didn't
engage in a political discussion with a thousand people, so - shut up!
I'm not saying the level of discourse is always high,
I mean, I filled in for John when he went on maternity leave the first time,
And on my first video, 90 % of the comments just said:
Oh mah God, John has Bewbs!!1!
Sometimes we are gonna get breaking news from the middle of the seat of government,
and sometimes we are gonna have:
[slurring voice]: I just really love cats ... and...[sniffles]
I want them to be...[sniffle] ... on a rainbow...
The last 4 weeks have been pretty fraught
and there's been a lot going on in the media, and the world
that is kinda hard to talk about.
It makes us both want to talk -
ALL the time, and not know how to talk at all.
There's a lot of...split opinions.
It's hard to sort of know what to say to people who are
of a different viewpoint than you.
Without screaming, or ripping out your hair,
or just go nuts and turn into some kind of crazy Troll
just going around the internet, going, "Troll Troll Troll Troll, I just wanna watch the world burn!"
And that is not productive.
Bu it doesn't mean we can't talk about these things that are difficult
where our opinions differ wildly
in fact, we HAVE to talk about these things. And I think in many ways,
the Internet is teaching us how to talk to each other.
In a big way, in a big way that we've never done before.
and we are just learning the language of mass discussion.
But it's easy to say we can use the internet to talk about things,
we all know it's actually really difficult. That's why, you know,
the one rule of the internet is: "Don't read the comments!!"
But Okay. Too late. You've read the comments,
it's already done, what do you do now?
Pause. Breathe! Look at some cats!
And ask yourself:
What do you want to accomplish?
Do you want to further a good cause that you are already part of,
or do you want to punch a Troll in the face?
And you probably want to...
...do both of those things.
But you're probably only going to to be able to accomplish one of them.
And you probably shouldn't be so focused on one.
Does it improve the situation, or the cause, or whatever it is your trying to promote
or encourage, or talk about?
Or just punch a Troll in the face?
And the answer, unfortunately, is "probably not".
It doesn't make your side look good,
it doesn't further the discussion,
so therefore, sadly, a lot of time you're not going to
be able to make that comment into a teachable moment!
What am I even talking about?
Just - GO for it. Just answer ALL the Trolls. Do it. NOW!
Troll Patrol starts now! Let's do this thing!
Honestly, start here. Start on this video, start looking in the comments,
and be like, "UR DUMB" - "NO, UR Dumb". - "BOOBS!"
No one knows how to "internet". If anybody tells you they know how to internet,
Just go tell them to go eat some watermelon,
because that's the only thing that makes sense in this mixed up world of ours.
I don't know what you people want from me.
Just follow me on Twitter or something, I dunno.
[mumbling] I'm good at Twitter. I'm good at Twitter, I'm not...
...I'm not great at videos.
I'm very, very good at Twitter, though.
go there.
[unintelligible, squeaking, high-pitched]
[high-pitched]: I'm sorry